voilà j'étais sûr c'est l'empreinte
ferme en spectacle et j'entends salle
noire croire la violence tout de suite
des gens qui votent front national parce
que c'est ce qui m'énerve c'est que
j'assume pas souvent de but de ces
messieurs a suivi c'est cool message
aura lâché vraiment perdu parce que je
me dise pas possible on est en 21e
siècle on est en france pendant un
spectacle d'humour c'est pas possible si
j'ai pas entendu ça c'est pour ça que je
demande trois fois pour laisser une
chance de désamorcer de s'excuser de
dire mais nan j'rigole je leur demande
pardon
et là j'entends une voix ferme et sans
équivoque il dit j'ai dit sale noir donc
là en moins tabou
j'ai des idées de violence sûr j'ai
envie de descendre sur cd et que ça
finisse aux mains et j'ai un sursaut de
jeu c'est pas de lucidité aux 2,2 de
sensibilité de fragilité qui je me dis
ou avenants ce n'est pas la bonne
solution
j'ai pas répondre à la violence par
l'arrivée par la violence - dans mon
spectacle je prône la tolérance je
prenais le vivre ensemble
je prône l'amour dans que en tant
qu'artiste moussan en tant qu'homme je
ne pourrais aller que l'on sait que dans
cette direction là donc je prend le
parti de mettre cette personne face à sa
propre à sa propre bêtise mais de
refuser un médaillon on a mal
c'est à dire à part de la gêne pour 3
dvd pour toi et je te dis je vais me
taire les gens ont ri peut-être pensant
que c'était un complice tellement
c'était gros c'est inimaginable
aujourd'hui quelqu'un puisse se lever et
dire sale noir dans l'impunité totale
devant tout le monde
quand j'ai vu la vidéo quand j'ai vu
tous les messages de soutien que j'ai vu
que j'ai reçues quand j'ai fait des
histoires que légèrement attentes et ils
m'ont tous dit quelqu'un de médiatiser
tu ne peux pas laisser passer ça ce
serait envoyer un mauvais signe pour le
pour les personnes qui vivent ça au
quotidien
donc oui je ne peux pas laisser passer
ça et je fais porter main en jouant les
politiques toute l'année qui qui qui qui
parfois divise qui est parfois je
cherche un soufflé sur des oeufs sur des
braises
je me dis là quand je passe quelque
chose comme ça et j'ai envie aussi de
voir le soutien des politiques il ya
beaucoup de racisme en france si on ne
peut pas le nier il faut le combattre
tous ensemble en fait le racisme n'est
pas une question qui doit intéresser que
les noirs ou que les gens victimes de
racisme
c'est une question que l'on intéresser
tout le monde c'est une question d'ordre
public ça ça touche toute la france le
racisme c'est la peur ou la bêtise ou le
manque d'éducation
donc on va pas le rester ce n'est pas la
violence quelqu'un de d2 de réciter son
quelqu'un d'ignorants et semant
quelqu'un qui a pris par ses parents qui
a pris par son environnement qui a qui a
mal appris donc c'est vraiment un
travail qu'on combatte fermé qui passe
par la pédagogie qui passe par les
professeurs qui passe par les éducateurs
qui passe par l'état qui passe par les
institutions de la république
nous sommes tous français souvent
j'entends des rentre chez toi chez moi
c'est la france je vous montrerai nulle
part je suis en france c'est un pays
multiculturel
c'est d'autres forces c'est pas une tare
des différents le vivre ensemble c'est
chacun vient avec sa différence mais
vivre ensemble c'est de ne pas faire
semblant
je ne vois plus les couleurs pour moi il
ya plus de noirs un peu de blanc ya plus
de gros y'a plus il ya des grillades et
mais qui a des roues et des blancs et
des noms
des cram il ya des hommes pour moi le
vivre ensemble c'est d'accepter toutes
ses différences et de vivre avec ça il
ya beaucoup plus de français qui veulent
vivre en harmonie avec tout le monde que
des racistes donc vous ne gagnerez
jamais on partira pas la différence
gadrat la mixité ghana c'est un combat
qui prendra le temps que ça prendra mais
les racistes vous ne gagnerez jamais